bonjour à tous ravi de vous retrouver
sur public sénna tout au long du mois de
septembre je vous propose de voir et de
revoir les moments forts de la séance
lors de la dernière session
parlementaire car tout au long du mois
de septembre et bien les sénateurs sont
absents du Palais du Luxembourg du en
séance publique car ils sont en campagne
en effet à la fin du mois de septembre
le 28 très exactement se tiendront les
élections sénatoriales qui permettront
de renouveler la moitié de la Haute
Assemblée place cet après-midi à
l'adoption d'un texte très concernant et
sur lequel les sénateurs ont largement
avré une proposition de lo relative à
l'encadrement et au développement des
stages les sénateurs ont largement
amélioré la condition de vie des
stagiaires avec notamment l'augmentation
de leur gratification qui passe de 436 à
523 € par mois et qui sera obligatoire à
partir de 2 mois de stage c'est
l'adoption de ce texte que je vous
propose de revoir cet après-midi
monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président je je je
m'exprimer non pas en tant que
rapporteur mais à titre personnel
quelques instants bien évidemment
l'article 1emer je le voterai il y a pas
de souci parce que je considère que le
texte qui n vient de l'Assemblée et le
travail que nous faisons ici est tout à
fait productif je voudrais
réétirer mon mon regret
du vote de l'amendement de Monsieur
barbier qui revient sur les dispositions
que nous avions prises concernant la
durée du stage à 35 he c'estàdire la
durée légale du travail j'y reviendrai
pas par contre madame la ministre je
continue être vigilant et je n'exclus
pas de voir en Commission permanente si
on peut faire quelque chose car je ne
suis pas convaincu je ne suis pas
convaincu je ne suis pas convaincu que
nous avons pris un amendement adopté
unamendement madame proc pour faire en
sorte que les employeurs ne puissent pas
diminuer la gratification quand il y a
des ponts ce que nous avions vérifié
dans un certain nombre de de sociétés je
pense que je souhaite que l'on puisse
vérifier à partir de là que la
gratification quand la durée du temps de
travail dépasse les 35 he et bien
augmenter à du proportion du temps de
travail dépassé des 35 he donc pour
l'instant je n'ai pas je je ne dis pas
que c'est que c'est pas possible j'ai
j'ai un doute je reste dans le doute et
je pense qu'il faut que ce doute soit
levé parce que c'est au moins un minima
que dans la mesure où l'amendement de
monsieur barer a été adopté que
maintenant le temps de travail peut-être
porté à plus d'heur que les 35h
réglementa que la gratification suiv en
même temps le même mouvement je vous
remercie monsieur le
Président
bien je vais donc mettre au voix le vote
au vote cet article 1er ainsi
rectifié amendé pardon qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient donc l'article 1er
est
adopté à ce stade je souhaiterais vous
rappeler que normalement on arrête à
minuit et
demi et que comme vous avez pu le
voir si nous n'avons pas terminé nous
reprendrons dans les semaines suivantes
comme ainsi que la voilà et oui on peut
arriver à terminer à condition que
chacun y mette un peu du en moi je n'y
vois pas de
d'inconvénient bien alors après
l'article 1er euh j'ai un amendement
numéro 7 qui est présenté par Monsieur
Desessard par cet amendement nous
souhaitons confier à l'Observatoire de
la vie étudiante une mission de
statistique et d'études sur les stages
aujourd'hui notre pays manque
cruellement de données fiables sur les
stagiaires pour éclairer l'action
publique dans ce domaine cela a été dit
à plusieurs reprises mais nous ne
pouvons estimer précisément aujourd'hui
le nombre de stagiaires en France nos
estimations varient de 1,6 million à 2
millions de personnes ce qui représente
une marge d'erreur de 20 %. pour
connaître plus précisément les
conditions de vie d'études de travail
des stagiaires il convient qu'un
organisme puisse nous livrer des
statistique FiBL l'Observatoire de la
vie étudiante qui s'est spécialisé dans
l'étude du monde étudiant pourrait se
charger de ces missions puisque ses
attributions actuelles sont connexes il
conviendra bien entendu de doter cette
structure de plus personnel l'article 40
nous empêchant d'alourdir les charges
publiques je vous demande madame la
ministre de nous aider à y remédier bien
monsieur le rapporteur quel est votre
avis favorable de la commission madame
la
ministre monsieur le Président Monsieur
le le sénateur le gouvernement aura une
position un peu différente de celle du
rapporteur parce que nous considérons
que un travail est en cours l'OV est
déjà tout à fait habilité à produire des
études sur les stagiaires puisque les
stagiaires sont des étudiants quand les
stagiaires sont des étudiants les
éléments quantifiés sont déjà produit et
contribu à la production de l'enquête
statistique réalisée chaque année par
les services de la DG CP donc les
services de la Direction Générale
d'enseignement supérieur et de
l'insertion professionnelle mais il
reste limité aux seuls universités aux
établissements qui dépendent directement
du du ministère conscient qu'il est
nécessaire de développer les
statistiques sur les stages le
gouvernement s'est engagé dans une
réflexion sur ce thème avec notamment
les services de l'INC des réunions de
travail ont déjà été conduites cette
année et vont se poursuivre pour définir
un mode de recueil statistique plus
pertinent et pérenne au niveau national
ainsi nous pourrons assurer un meilleur
suivi des stages et des
stagiaires mais pour le pour le moment
pardon il semble toutefois sans objet
d'indiquer dans la loi une mission
particulière vis-à-vis des étudiants
lesquels sont déjà une cible d'étude
pour l'Observatoire de la vie étudiante
c'est pourquoi je m'en remets à votre
sagesse pour éviter comme vous l'avez
dit vous-même d'allourdir un texte et je
vous propose de de retirer cet
amendement en sachant que je partage
votre préoccupation et que les
différences chiffret que vous indiquez
peuvent s'expliquer mais je veux pas
allonger le temps d'intervention et je
vous expliquerai à quoi elles sont des
c'est
ça n'ai pas dit que j'alourdissais le
texte puisque simplement je demande dans
mon amendement de rajouter aider
stagiaires
donc c'est quand même pas alourdir le
test que de demander que a des
stagiaires ça veut dire qu'on pointe
particulièrement que ce ne sont pas
simplement les des statistiques sur les
étudiants mais qu'on fait attention
aussi au stages et au stagiaires et vous
avez dit madame la ministre que vous
comptez le faire donc il s'agit de
rajouter le mot et des stagiaires bon
voilà donc après après j'ai dit que ça
pouvait alourdir le budget puisquon on
va demander à s'occuper des stagiaires
mais madame la ministre vous m'avez dit
il le fait déjà donc c'est là que je il
y a pas de frais supplémentair puisqu'il
le fait déjà on pointe simplement par
mon amendement en mettant le mot et des
stagiaire que il faut pas oublier la
dimension de formation dans les
entreprises donc je mets au voix cet
amendement numéro 7 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il est
adopté après l'article
1er je
suis saisi d'un amendement 34 34
présenté par Madame Pasquet ou non
madame pardon excusez-moi non mais je
joue au qure coins je joue au qure coins
c'est pour ça
comme vous le savez la rédaction de
l'article L 1221-2 du Code du travail
prévoit qu'une entreprise embauche un
stagiaire à la fin de son stage alors la
durée du stage est déduite de la période
d'essès toutefois il ne s'agit que d'une
déduction partielle puisque cette
réduction ne s'opère que dans la limite
de 50 % de la durée prévue au départ
ainsi le stagiaire est embauché à la fin
d'un stage qui a duré 4 mois et dont le
contrat prévoit une période d'cès de 2
mois ne doit plus réaliser une période
décès que d'un mois Mo c'est tout à fait
positif pour autant il nous semble qu'il
est possible de prévoir que dès lors que
le recrutement en CDI fait suite à un
stage réussi par définition la durée du
stage doit être intégralement déduite de
la période d'essès et non pas pour
moitié cela nous paraît d'autant plus
opportun que ces périodes d'essès
peuvent atteindre 3 mois pour un agent
de maîtrise et 4 mois pour le
recrutement d'un cadre or si l'employeur
décide de recruter un un stagiaire c'est
qu'il a déjà la certitude que cet ancien
stagiaire devenu nouveau salarié détient
les compétences requises à la réussite
du poste qu'il s'est vu attribuer cela
participe d'un mouvement de sécurisation
d'entrée dans la vie professionnelle
sans constituer pour autant une
contrainte de taille à la charge des
employeurs c'est pourquoi nous
souhaitons que notre amendement soit
adoptéur avis de la commission
oui monsieur le Président le régime
actuel résulte d'un accord national
interprofessionnel de 2011 signé
l'unanimité par les partenaires sociaux
de plus le stage est déjà déduit
intégralement de la période d'cès
lorsque l'emploi en question est en
correspondance avec les activités qui
avaient été confié au stagiaires il
s'agit d'après moi du cas de figure le
plus majoritaire le stage constituant
une forme de prérecrutement pour un
poste précis il me semble qu'il faut sur
ce point respecter la volonté des
partenaires sociaux donc c'est une
demande de retrait mon avis
défavorable madame la ministre même avis
même motif monsieur le Président
bien donc je mets au voix
je mets au voix l'amendement 34 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté à l'article
2 un amendement de Marseille qui
tombe un amendement de Monsieur Charles
Revet donc le 63 rectifié B en
discussion commune oui merci monsieur le
Président la loi 1440 du 20 janvier 2014
garantissant l'avenir et la justice du
système de retraite a prévu que les
étudiants ayant effectué un stage
éligible à une gratification donc d'une
durée supérieure à 2 mois pourront
valider celui-ci pour le retraite pour
assurer la traçabilité de ces stages
l'inscription des stagiaires sur le
registre du personnel de l'organisme
d'accueil apparaît parfaitement cohérent
étendre cette formalité à tous les
stages apparaît disproportionné voire
dissuasive pour les organismes d'accueil
imagine-on un artisan ou un agriculteur
ouvrir un registre du personnel pour un
stage de 15 jours par exemple il est
donc proposé d'en rester à une
obligation qui ne concernerait que les
stages éligibles à une gratification
pour les raisons exposées
icidessus
bien l'amendement de Madame linman tombe
madame Cohen non madame paset
l'amendement
merci monsieur le
Président depuis 2008 les entreprises
doivent disposer d'une liste des
conventions de stage qu'elle conclut ce
document a pris la forme avec la loi
chpion du 28 juillet 2011 d'un registre
des conventions de stage qui est
toutefois distinct
euh du registre unique du personnel qui
pour mémoire les noms prénoms de tous
les salariés de l'établissement dans
l'ordre des embauches ainsi qu'une liste
d'indication complémentaire dans
l'emploi ou la qualification les députés
ont souhaité par souci de simplification
la disparition de ce registre des
conventions et faire figurer dans une
partie spécifique du registre unique du
personnel les noms et prénoms des
stagiaire accueilli dans l'organisme
signataire nous souscrivons pleinement à
cette mesure et dans la continuité de
cette disposition et nous semble que le
registre unique du personnel devrait
également indiquer la durée du stage et
l'é mississions confié au stage
cette précision nous a paru utile afin
de permettre aux représentants du
personnel de disposer de tous les
éléments qui leur semblent utile et de
faciliter les démarches des agents de
contrôle de l'inspection du travail et
des ursaves qui ont accès à ce
document
bien monsieur le rapporteur quel est
votre avis sur ces deux amendements sur
l'amendement sur l'amendement de
Monsieur revet donc demande
d'inscription des stagiaires et donc
pour ceux ici de l'enseignement
supérieur l'intérêt d' ire les
stagiaèires dans le registre unique du
personnel et d'assurer le leur suivi
dans l'organisme d'accueil par tous ceux
délégués du personnel inspecteur du
travail qui ont axé ce n'est pas une
formalité insurmontable donc c'est un
avis défavorable et l'amendement de
Madame Cohen je je demanderai le retrait
parce que ce sont des mesures qui à mon
sens relèvent du pouvoir réglementaire
puisqu'il s'agit d'inscrire la durée du
stage et lesmissions confié au
stagiaires madame la ministre quel est
votre avis sur ces de amendements Mame
avis pour les mêmes raisons monsieur le
Président bien je mets donc au voit
l'amendement 63 rectifié bis qui est
pour qui est
contre n'est pas
adopté et le
35 qui est
pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté non plus je mets donc au voit
l'article 2 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 2 est adopté après l'article
2 chez nous en sommes à l'amendement 37
présenté par Madame Collen oui monsieur
le Président mes chers collègues vous le
savez les organisations syndicales de
salariés celles représentant les
étudiants et le collectif Génération
Précaire que notre rapporteur a
d'ailleurs auditionné propose que les
stagiaires soit pris en compte dans
l'effectif des entreprises à du
proportion de leur temps de présence
dans cette entreprise cela nous apparaît
être une mesure tout à fait souhaitable
afin de lutter contre une forme d'abus
qui consisterait pour certains
employeurs à recruter de manière plus ou
moins permanente des stagiaires de telle
sorte que tour à tour ils correspondent
à des postes permanents tout en évitant
que l'effectif administratif de
l'entreprise excède certains seuil
légaux comme celui des 50 donc il nous
paraît très important de pouvoir accéder
à à ces demandes et donc de voter cet
amendement monsieur le rapporteur avis
de la commission oui monsieur le
Président je resterai dans la même
logique puisqu'il s'agit de prendre en
compte les stagiaires dans l'effectif de
l'organisme d'accueil l'appartenance à
une entreprise repose sur la signature
d'un contrat de travail et l'existence
d'un lien de subordinisation avec
l'employeur ce n'est pas le cas des
stagiaires et il ne me paraît pas
souhaitable de faire évoluer cette
situation c'est un avis défavorable
madame la
ministre même avis pour les mêmes
raisons on a rappelé à main reprise que
le stage n'était pas un contrat de
travail ni un emploi et il y aurait une
confusion qui serait amenée par cet
amendement donc avis défavorable
monsieur le cessard explication de
vote j'interviens pour expliquer mon
vote puisque je vais pas voter
l'amendement proposé par le CRC mais
j'en suis pas loin
alors non parce que je reste encore dans
l'idée de ce projet de loi enfin de
cette proposition de loi que le stage
fait partie de la formation alors après
on pourrait on pourrait dire mais à un
autre moment de dire que dans le
registre du personnel on peut noter tous
les flux des stagiaires de façon
différente mais là et vous l'avez dit
Madame Cohen vous avez dit c'est la
demande de de Génération précaire et ben
effectivement Génération Précaire eux
ils parlent d'un constat ils disent
beaucoup de stages aujourd'hui sont en
réalité des emplois il faut absolument
lutter contre ça et pour cela il faut
les inscrire dans le registre de
personnel leur donner des droits parce
queils sont
utilisés
aujourd'hui nous le groupe écologiste on
a
choisi la la vision du rapporteur et
donc du gouvernement puisque le
gouvernement a la même optique c'est que
le stage fait partie de la formation
mais Génération Précaire pose un vrai
problème est-ce qu'on pourra longtemps
continuer comme
cela puisque beaucoup de stages
sontutilisés comme premier emploi et eux
ils disent considérons qu'il y a des
vraiment des premiers emplois prenons-le
en compte et faisons en sorte qu'ils ont
des conditions décentes et ce à quoi je
je l'urait
répondu à à ceux et à celles avec qui
j'en ai discuté que c'était rentré dans
un contrat premier embauche c'est-à-dire
avec un un revenu qui serait moindre
donc pour ce là pour le moment il est
pas question de légitimer le fait que
des stages soi considérés comme un
emploi avec une gratification inférieure
au SMIC donc voilà pourquoi je ne
rentrerai pas comme le rapporteur l'a
indiqué dans cette logique même si je
sais qu'il y a beaucoup d'abus et je
resterai dans la logique que le stage
fait partie de la formation il n'empêche
et je sais que le gouvernement va
considérer que ce n'est pas le moment
d'en parler mais il n'empêche qu'on
pourrait considérer qu'il pourrait y
avoir une allocation
d'étudiants pour tous les étudiants mais
à ce moment-là ce n'est plus la même
chose ce n'est pas l'entreprise qui pie
l'étudiant en stage mais c'est une
allocation d'étudiant pour tout les
étudiants c'est une autre question alors
je sais que vous nêtes pas d'accord les
jeunes socialistes à une époque étaient
d'accord avec une allocation d'étudiants
uneité pour les étudiants nous y sommes
encore favorabl donc sera toujours temps
d'en discuter dans quelques mois ou dans
quelques temps bien
aujourd'hui j'en resterai dans la
logique du texte c'est-à-dire que le
stage est un moment de formation
porteur pasonger mais juste un mot
souscrit au propos de Jean deessur mais
l'article 2 répond je pense aux
inquiétudes de de des rédacteurs je
voudrais quand même inser sur un point
c'est que si on introduit le dans le
calcul des effectifs de l'entreprise on
risque se retrouver pour pour certaines
entreprises avec des effets de seuil
avec toutes les conséquences de l'effet
de seuil donc je pense que c'est pas
c'est pas dans ce texte qu'il faut
ajouter les stagiaire à l'effectif de
l'entreprise le noir pour explication de
vote monsieur le Président je suis tout
à fait convaincu par les arguments qui
ont été exposés aussi bien par le
rapporteur que Madame la Ministre alors
deux choses d'abord vra avoir
confirmation que le stagiare apparaît
dans le bilan social des entreprise de
plus de 300 salariés premièrement
deuxièmement je ferai quand même une
remarque à notre collègue de cessa quand
il parle d'une gratification pour les
étudiants ça me rappelle voyons ce qui s
passé en 2006 lorsque un tel dispositif
était proposé par un gouvernement de
l'époque dispositif contre lequel il y
avait une forte mobilisation est-ce que
vous n'avez pas le sentiment mon cher
collègue que vous rapprochez les
propositions qui avaient été faites par
un certain Premier ministre qui
s'appelait monsieur de
Villepin
bien
bien je mets donc au voit cet amendement
37 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté je mets au
voix l'article 3 qui est pour qui est
contre qui s'abstient l'article 3 est
adopté à l'article
4 j'ai un amendement 149 présenté par le
gouvernement madame la
ministre 149
monsieur le Président il s'agit
d'unamendement de cohérence avec
l'amendement de suppression du
gouvernement à l'article
1er l'inspection du travail n'ayant pas
pour mission de contrôler le respect des
stipulations pédagogiques de la
convention de stage il n'y a donc pas
lieu d'étendre sa compétence sur ce
sujet j'en profite pour préciser au
sénateur de cessar que si on inscrit
dans le registre unique du personnel les
stagiaires c'est pour vérifier que le
nombre de stagiaires n'est pas en
excédent par rapport au dispositif
législatif et préciser ensuite par
décret ça ça n'est pas parce qu'on les
considère comme des membres salariés du
personnel monsieur le rapporteur quel
est votre avis sur cet
amendement favorable je mets au voie la
l'amendement 149 du gouvernement qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement est adopté et Madame
procacia nous présente le 84 ctifier bis
oui il s'agit euh euh lorsque les
étudiants sont revenus ont fait un
rapport de stage où on pu dire
effectivement comment c'était déroulé le
stage et et s'ils ont effectué un
travail et non pas un stage en
formation moi je continue à penser que
les stagiaires ne sont pas les plus à
même souvent de pouvoir
contacter le l'inspection du travail
donc je suggère d'étendre la possibilité
aux autorités académiques compétentes de
saisir elle aussi l'inspection du
travail si elle voyait des
manquements monsieur le rapporteur
oui monsieur le Président donc il s'agit
de prévoir que l'inspection du travail
peut intervenir sur cisine des autorités
académiques pour contrôler le manquement
de la législation bon la question qu'on
peut se poser est-il nécessaire que la
loi précise que l'inspecteur d'académie
pourra saisir l'inspection du travail
s'il apprend qu'un organisme ne règle
pas ne respecte pas la réglementation
ceci étant comme il nous est très
difficile de mettre un avis défavorable
sur quelque chose qui nous semble tout à
fait logique mais qui doit se faire
normalement donc c'est un avis de un
avis favorable de la commission mais ça
ça à mon avis ça n'apporte pas
grand-chose madame procassia la
situation actuelle
donc je pense que le mieux aurait été de
le retirer en ayant la certitude que ça
fonctionne déjà comme ça et que la
possibilité est déjà offerte à
l'inpection d'académie de saisir
l'inspection du travail s'ils sont
alertés d'un manquement à la
réglementation serait peut-être ça
éviterait peut-être qu'on nous reproche
que la loi est trop bavarde comm on nous
le reproche de temps en temps voilà
madame la ministre
oui monsieur le Président comme il est
toujours possible comme ça a été dit
d'ailleurs ça vient d'être rappelé par
le rapporteur et même de bonne
administration que les autorités
académiques transmettent les
informations qu'elle jugent utille à
l'inspection du travail il ne paraît pas
nécessaire au gouvernement que la loi le
prévoit puisqu'on est là dans dans une
redondance et dans l'énoncé du d'une
évidence donc le gouvernement avait émis
un avis
défavorable
bien non dans la mesure où il y a déjà
la possibilité je vais le retirer par
contre j'aimerais bien que vous me
disiez si ça arrive de temps en temps si
vous avez connaissance de l'inspection
du travail saisie une fois par des
autorités bien madame la ministre vous
souhaitez répondre bien sûr monsieur le
Président si vous en prie si vous
autoriser oui il y a il y a des cas
effectivement et
les les personnes compétentes du
ministère du Travail me le
confirme l'amendement 84 rectifi bis est
donc retiré et je mets au voix l'article
4 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 4 est adopté à l'article
5 madame procasscia toujours oui s'agit
euh de requalification alors lorsque le
stagiaire a effectué effectivement une
tâche régulière qui correspond à un
emploi
de salarié permanent sans aller jusqu'à
la requalification complète du contrat
de travail on introduit on propose
d'introduire
l'obligation que l'organisme rémunère au
SMIC ou en tout cas un pourcentage du
SMIC qui serait déterminé par décret
mais tout est déterminé par décret dans
ce texte
euh
comment bien monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président donc
sur le principe la Commission et
moi-même nous sommes favorables à cette
initiative de Madame procacia il faut
sanctionner les employeurs qui ont
recours au stagiair en lieu et place de
salariés permanents toutefois pour
qu'une telle indemnité puisse être versé
il faut qu'elle soit allouée par un
tribunal qui aura jugé que la convention
de stage n'était pas conforme à la
législation seul le contentieux de la
requalification de la convention contrat
de travail permet d'y parvenir c'est
donc un amendement d'appel en quelque
sorte qui me semble inabouti en l'état
mais sur lequel il faut poursuivre notre
réflexion donc nous avionons décidé de
nous en remettre à la sagesse de notre
assemblée sauf ave contraire peut-être
du gouvernement mais ça me
semble madame la ministre quel est donc
l'avis du
Gouvernement monsieur le Président le le
gouvernement un avis
qui a concerté avec le ministère du
Travail à ce sujet parce que
l'affectation d'un stagiaire sur un
poste de travail permanent dans
l'entreprise se fait toujours au
détriment de de l'embauche d'un salarié
ce qui nous gêne par rapport à la
définition tout de même d'un stagiaire
qui est encore une fois un étudiant ou
un élève en situation de formation et
pas non pas en situation de de
remplacement d'un salarié donc la
requalification c'est les demandé et le
juste dédommagement du du stagiaire et
entraîne la sanction nécessaire de
l'infraction ainsi le stagiaire aura
droit au rappel des salaires qui aurait
dû lui être versé ce salaire ne pouvant
être inférieur au SMIC mais également à
l'ensemble des droits qui sont associés
au statut du salarié con j'ai payé le
cchéant indemnité de licenciement et il
faut prévoir qu'en cas d'infraction le
stagiaire ne reçoit qu'une indemnité
compensatrice déterminant en pourcentage
du SMIC je prévoir comme vous comme
comme c'est proposé dans votre
amendement que le stagère ne reçoivent
qu'une indemnité compensatrice euh en
pourcentage du SMIC qui irait donc à
l'encontre de l'objectif de cette cette
PPL qui de protéger le droit des
stagiaires et de lutter contre le
recours abusif au stages voilà pourquoi
cet amendement nous gêne même si' il est
plein de bonnes intentions mais il va à
l'encontre de la définition même du du
stagiaire
et je je regarde d'ailleurs moiême je
regarde ma formulation parce que c'est
pas dans l'entreprise c'est dans
l'organisme d'accueil quel qu'il soit ça
peut être une administration publique ça
peut être une association ça peut être
une une entreprise donc il faut éviter
de stigmatiser l'entreprise là aussi
c'est l'organisme ou l'entité d'accueil
du
stagiare bien je mets donc au voix cet
amend
pardon je l'avais compris
excusez-moi bien donc je mets au voix
l'amendement 129 rectifié qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas adopté et je mets
au vote l'article 5 qui est pour
l'article 5
qui est contre qui s'abstient l'article
5 est
adopté à l'article 6 c'est Monsieur
Charles Revet oui monsieur le Président
je suis un petit peu ennuyé parce que
j'ai une bonne mémoire mais quand même
comme on travaille plusieurs soirs
différents je sais plus quel sort avait
été réservé à
l'amandement 59 et donc comme c'est il
s'agissait d'un amendement de
coordination peut-être que monsieur le
rapporteur va pouvoir m pororter des
précisions comme ça il est c'est
l'amendement 59 a été rejeté et donc
comme c'est un amendement de
coordination c'est évidemment un avis
défavorable monsieur revet monsieur
revet le retire avant que madame la
ministre ne donne son avis d'ailleurs et
donc je mets au voix l'article 6 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'article 6 est adopté la l'article 7
même vote même vote il est adopté après
l'article 7 j'ai plusieurs amendements
en discussion commune danst le prer le
51 sont des amendements identiques et
présentés par Madame Ferrand merci
monsieur le Président l'objet de cet
amendement est d'assurer la pérennité et
la traçabilité des financements des
gratifications de stage des travailleurs
sociaux en effet le fond de transition
doté de 5,3 million d' dont madame la
ministre vous avez annoncé la création
paraît bien insuffisant pour financer
les gratifications des stagiaires dans
le secteur public en 2008 20 millions
d'euros avaient été dégagés pour
financer ces gratifications dans le
secteur associatif faute d'une
ingénierie financière adaptée ces
crédits ont été dispersés et se sont
dilués dans les budgets des
établissements et services sociaux et
médicauociaux pour résoudre ce problème
nous proposons de créer une enveloppe
d'intérêt général pour les établissement
destiné à financer les stages des élèves
ou étudiants en travail social elle
serait financé par redéploiement de
crédit et par le fond de transition
annoncé ce qui permettrait de répondre
structurellement à la problématique liée
à la gratification des stagiaires dans
le secteur médico-social en effet les
formations initiales longues et les
formations continues des professionnels
dans les établissements et services
sociaux et médicos-sociaux ont toujours
reposé sur l'alternance entre les les
centres de formation et les institutions
ces structures accueillent donc de
nombreux stagiaires sur des périodes
longues qui doivent désormais recevoir
des gratifications financières leur coût
annuel tout financeur confondu a été
évalué en 2008 dans le secteur associ
associatif à 22,3 millions d'euros dont
4,7 à la charge de longdame notre
dispositif permet d'une part d'apporter
un soutien financier aux étudiants et
d'autre part de ne pas pénaliser les
structur d'accueil des stagiares pour
les établissements d'accueil des jeunes
enfants un envenant à la COG entre la
CAF et l'État devrait permettre de
redéployer les financements nécessaires
à la gratification des stages des
éducateurs de jeunes enfants enfin la
gratification des stagiaires en travail
social devrait être ajouté à l'arrêté
ministériel qui fixe la liste des mijac
dans les établissements de
santé bien
j'ai
trois amendements encore identiques donc
le second le 110 rectifié bis est
présenté par Madame
brugierre rectifier bis amendement
identique à celui que il est défendu il
est défendu il est défendu je vous
remercie monsieur Barbier amendement
identique
également il est défendu je vous
remercie et le 138
et défendu également il est défendu
également je vous remercie alors quel
est l'avis de la commission monsieur le
rapporteur alors monsieur le
Président des mesures de soutien ont
déjà été prises par le gouvernement
notamment la mise en place d'un fond de
soutien à la gratification des étudiants
en travail en travail social des Assises
du travail social sont maintenant
attendus pour débattre de l'avenir de
ces métiers cet amendement sous un abord
d' une technicité redoutable créer un
dispositif complexe et rigide qui se
finance par des redéploiements de crédit
dans l'objectif de dépenses
médico-social le champ exact des
organismes visés n'est pas précisé s'il
s'agit uniquement des établissements et
services médicaux-sociaux financés par
l'OGD alors cet amendement est satisfait
puisque depuis 2008 une enveloppe
annuelle de 4,7 million d'euros est
alloué pour les aider à accueillir des
stagiaires en revanche s'il s'agit de
prendre en charge les coûts qu'entraîne
l'accueil de stagiaires travailleurs
sociaux dans les services propres des
conseils généraux ainsi que dans les
établissements et services qui sont
entièrement financés par l'État et non
par l'assurance maladie la solution
proposée n'est pas pertinente en effet
le GD a un champ plus limité que celui
de l'ensemble de ces structures cela
aboutira à priver les éepad et les
établissements médicaux-sociaux d'une
partie de leurs ressources et à utiliser
des fonds destinés au financement des
soins à un usage qui ne leur correspond
pas l'assurance maladie n'a pas financé
la formation des travailleurs sociaux
mais bien la prise en charge médicalisée
en épable ou l'établissement ou
établissement pour personnes handicapé
on se trouverait donc dans ce cas un
transfert de charge qui serait
irreçevable au titre de l'article 40 il
y a donc deux cas de figures soit il
s'agit d'un dispositif qui n'apporte
rien qui est satisfait soit il est
recevable au titre de l'article
irrecevable au titre de l'article 40
puisque l'assurance maladie est appelé à
prendre en charge de nouvelles dépenses
qui jusqu'à présent n'était pas de son
ressort j'invite donc les auteurs de
l'amendement à préciser leur volonté
mais je je pense que dans ces cas-là le
mieux c'est de solliciter l'avis du
Gouvernement C c'est laavis de la
commission me semble que nous avons
résumé la situation et que la BAL est
dans le camp du gouvernement
maintenant madame la ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement sur ces
amendements
identiques monsieur le président
mesdames messieurs les sénateurs je
ferai une réponse globale puisque la
gratification des des stages au sein des
établissements sociaux et
médicos-sociaux relevant de l'objectif
national de dépenses d'assurance maladie
est applicable depuis 2008 depuis cette
date une enveloppe de 4 milli7 est
fléché annuellement dans la circulairire
de campagne pour le financement de cette
gratification il n'est donc pas juste de
dire qu'il n'existe aucun crédit pour
financer les S les stages dans le
secteur médico-social et que ces crédits
ne seraient pas précisément identifiés
et fléchés ce qui ressort surtout de
l'examen de la consommation de ces
crédits c'est que depuis leur mise en
place ils sont systématiquement
sous-consommés ce n'est donc pas
l'obligation de gratifier les stages qui
explique les difficultés de certains
étudiants à trouver un stage dans ses
établissements les difficultés actuelles
rencontré par les étudiants en travail
social pour trouver des stages ne se
situent pas dans le secteur médico
social associatif dont je que je viens
d'évoquer mais dans les secteurs
nouvellement soumis tels qu'ils ont été
défin par la loi sur dans le casadre de
la loi sur l'enseignement supérieur et
la recherche qui était votée le 22
juillet dernier et sont des nouveaux
secteurs qui ont été soumis à la
gratification il concerern
principalement les collectivités
territoriales puisque l'État était déjà
soumis et le présent amendement qui ne
s'intéresse qu'à la question des
établissements relevant de l'objectif
nationale de dépenses de l'assurance
maladie ne résout pas cette difficulté
nouvelle cette difficulté nouvelle nous
l'avons identifié lors de la discussion
de cette PPL à l'Assemblée nationale
et non d'ailleurs pardonnez-moi c'est
l'ORS de c'est
c'est confusion de ma part c'est lors de
l'examen de la loi sur l'enseignement
supérieur et la recherche que nous
avions identifié cette difficulté pour
les collectivités territoriales et puis
un certain nombre d'associations dont
une que vous connaissez bien et qui très
active et très réactive sur le sujet
nous avait fortement alerté nous avons
donc négocié avec le ministère des
affaires sociales un fond de transition
qui a été créé qui est destiné à le les
difficultés temporaires rencontré par
les petites structures notamment les
petites communes ou les petits
établissements publics relevant de la
fonction publique territoriale et nous
avons mis en place un fond de de
transition de
5 300000 € on a fait une évaluation et
on a même fait une évaluation assez
large parce que je pense que
l'expérience va nous montrer que comme
pour le premier fond il ne sera pas
sollicité
dans totalement tout en étant euh des
lieux de stage parle des des petites
collectivités particulièrement
intéressant pour les étudiants ils
peuvent être en difficulté en effet pour
financer les gratification cette année
puisqu'ils n'ont pas pu l'anticiper lors
de la construction de leur budget donc
nous avons mis en place ces dispositions
transitoires qui répondent à toutes les
questions posées par ces amendements et
tout cela s'est fait vraiment en en
concertation avec l'ensemble des
collectivités concernées mais là encore
nous avons voulu étendre au plus grand
nombre des stagiaires les mêmes
dispositifs pour
favoriser l'équité vis-à-vis de
l'ensemble des stagiaires même si je
j'anticipe cette équité n'a pas pu être
complètement globale mais je vois qu'il
n'écoute pas monsieur de César donc
voilà je vous propose un avis
défavorable bien je vais donc mettre au
voie euh ces amendements
qui est
pour qui est
contre qui
s'abstient les ces amendements ne sont
pas
adoptés après pardon non
après l'article 7 je suis saisi de trois
amendements
identiques le premier
53 est présenté par Madame FERR merci
monsieur le Président l'objet de cet
amendement est de permettre aux
entreprises qui ne trouvent pas
d'apprentis dans le dans leur secteur
d'activité les services notamment de ne
plus être sanctionné par le malus que
représente le versement de la
contribution supplémentaire à
l'apprentissage pour non respect du
Cotat de 4 %
d'apprentis il il sera de 5 % 2015 en
prenant en compte dans le calcul de ce
quota les stagiaires embauché en CDI par
l'entreprise à l'issue de leur stage
cette mesure ne peut qu'inciter les
entreprises à s'impliquer en faveur de
l'embauche des jeunes et de leur
formation et ainsi les aider à s'insérer
plus rapidement dans le monde du
travail amendement 89 identique madame
procacia il est défendu il est défendu
je vous remercie et le 119 rectifié
madame Laborde oui c'est le même
amendement nous l'avions déjà déposé
lors de la disc du projet de loi relatif
à la formation professionnelle et il a
été défendu par Madame ferra donc ce
sera parfait bien je vous remercie
monsieur le rapporteur quel est votre
avis sur ces trois amendements
identiques bien monsieur le Président le
C le CSA a pour objet de développer
l'alternance dans les grandes
entreprises où elle où elle est bien
moins répandue que dans l'artisanat par
exemple je ne suis pas convaincu qu'on
puisse assimiler un stagiaire de
l'enseignement supérieur à un apprenti
ou un jeune en contrat de
professionnalisation la politique
publique en faveur du développement de
l'alternance un objectif clair et la CSA
est l'un de ces outils faut-il faire des
exceptions au risque d'en diminuer
l'efficacité je n'en suis pas convaincu
par ailleurs comment savoir au moment du
stage et du calcul de la CSA si le
stagiaire va être embauché en CDI
ensuite s'il faut que le montant de
cette taxe soit régularisé
postérieurement cela va créer des
difficultés administratives très
importantes aussi bien pour les
entreprises que pour les services
fiscaux donc pour toutes ces raisons
c'est un avis défavorable aux trois
amendements madame la ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement même avis pour
les mêmes raisons monsieur le
Président bien je vais
donc mettre au voix ces trois
amendements c'est pour le pour ça ou
non pour 5389 oui c'est
pourel tous les tris bon donc je suis
euh saisi euh d'une demande de scrutin
public euh sur ces amendements de
demande présentée par le groupe euh
um je vous rappelle que nous avons un
avis défavorable de la commission et du
gouvernement qui doit donc être procédé
au scrutin public dans les conditions
fixées par l'article 56 du règlement et
le scrutin sera donc ouvert dans
quelques instants un
gar
est
ouvert
plus personne ne demande à voter donc le
scrutin est clos j'invite les secrétaire
à procéder au dépouillement du
scrutin
du scrutin numéro 182 sur les
amendements 53 89 et 119 rectifiés
nombre de votants 346 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
346 pour l'adoption
178 contre 168 le Sénat a
adopté
après l'article
7 nous avons un amendement 66 rectifié
bis monsieur
revet oui merci monsieur le Président si
si vous es d'accord je vais présenter en
même temps le 66 67 68 et 58 puisqu'ils
ont le même si ce sont pas les mêmes les
mêmes personnes concernées c'est le même
même type d'amendement qui concerne les
Aes soignants les auxiliaires depuis
agriculture les ambulanciers les
travailleurs sociaux les formations
comportent des enseignements magistraux
et des temps de stages professionnels
sur leur futur lieu d'exercice à ce
titre les professionnels susvisés
participent à la formation des élèves et
étudiants êes soignants dans le cadre de
ces cadres stages pratiques ainsi pour
ces étudiants élèves les stages
obligatoires conditionnent l'accès à la
profession et c'est vrai pour chacune
des secteurs que je indiqué il y a un
instant l'accès à la profession à
laquelle il se prépare et toute
difficulté pouvant y faire obstacle doit
être levé c'est pourquoi le présent
amendement vise les sages liés à un
cursus pédagogique intégré à la
formation de ces futurs professionnels
qui ne peuvent de par leur spécificité
bénéficier d'aucune forme de
rémunération de gratification à
l'exclusion des indemnités liées aux
contraintes engendrées par ces stages et
donc que les quatre amendements qui sont
différents puisque ça concerne des
personnes différentes mais ont le même
objet c'est pour ça que je les présente
en même temps j'ai bien compris monsieur
revet et je vous
remercie monsieur le rapporteur si vous
voulez bien donner votre avis sur les
quatre amendements donc puisqu'ils sont
légèrement différents mais je pense
qu'on peut donner un avis commun sur les
quatre oui monsieur présent ces quatre
amendements pour obligé d'exclure de
l'obligation de gratification des stages
donc des aides soignants des auxiliaires
de priculture
de Mir des des ambulanciers et des
travailleurs sociaux donc sur ces qure
amendements ça ne surprendra pas
monsieur rev un avis défavorable de la
commission madame la ministre quel est
l'avis du Gouvernement même avis pour
les mêmes motifs monsieur le Président
bien donc je vais mettre au voix
successivement ces quatre
amendements pour le 66 rectifié bis qui
est
pour
qui est
contre qui s'abstient il n'est pas
adopté pour le 60 rectifié bis même vote
même vote il n'est pas adopté non plus
le 68 rectifié bis même vote même vote
il n'est pas adopté et le 58 rectifié
bis même vote il n'est pas adopté non
plus après l'article
7 j'ai donc deux amendements en
discussion commune qui sont présentés
par Madame procacia
oui tout à fait le gouvernement a bien
annoncé son
intention de se lancer dans l'open data
et un certain nombre d'ailleurs de
ministères commencent à avoir des
plateformes intéressantes or en matière
de stage il apparaîtrait que si une
plateforme en ligne estitmise ça la
permettrait de donner des informations
concrètes sur les offres de stage sur
les droits des stag
sur les organismes
d'accueil ça permettrait d'éviter sans
doute des abus de mieux informer les
stagiaires ceux pour lesquels les stages
se sont mal déroulés euh pourrait en
parler décrire donc une telle base de
données nous paraît trit utile pour tout
le monde les entreprises d'accueil les
stagiaires les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur qui pourraient
suivre au fur à mesure des années et des
stages quand il y a des milliers
d'étudiants qui font des stages il y a
pas vraiment de regroupement qui peut se
faire ça contribuerait à la transparence
des pratiques et ça me paraît aller dans
les souhaits du gouvernement euh le 86
est simplement un amendement de
repli si le gouvernement me disait qu'il
a pas les moyens matériels ou financiers
de mettre en place c'est de demander un
rapport encore
qu'après l'intervention de notre
présidente
sur en commission sur tous les rapports
demandés qui ne sont jamais remis je
préférerais ne pas avoir à faire à
présenter l'amendement de
REP monsieur le rapporteur quel est
votre avis sur ces deux amendements
monsieur le Président cette la création
de cette plateforme publique
d'information c'est une idée
intéressante mais qui au vu de la
multiplicité des acteurs concernés nous
sommes très difficiles à mettre en œuvre
de plus ce n'est pas véritablement une
démarche de type Open Data car il n'y a
pas aujourd'hui de grande base de
données publiques à ce sujet sur lequel
l'accès serait restreint donc la
Commission a souhaité demander son avis
au gouvernement quant à l'amendement de
repli de Madame procacia la Commission
est assez défavorable à la
multiplication des demandes de rapport
donc c'est un avis défavorable madame la
ministre avis du gouvernement s'il vous
plaît oui monsieur le Président Madame
la la sénatrice en fait l'un de mes
prédécesseurs Laurent vouquier he pour
le nommer avait mis en place une avait
tenté de mettre en place une
centralisation des données sur les
stages en en donnant la la gestion à
l'onicep c'était une une banque de de
données mais ça n'a pas marché tout
simplement parce que ces offres se font
au niveau des territoires et que leur
centralisation s'est avérrait tout à
fait impossible donc là il s'agit pas d'
d'Open Data ou de
ou on est en dehors de suj là on est
simplement sur la difficulté à
recueillir à un niveau central et à
colationner à un niveau central des
données qui sont des données
territorialisées donc il nous semble
beaucoup plus intéressant de d'opérer ce
travail à un niveau territorialisé là on
dispose des données effectivement
efficace et sur l'OP data je vous dis au
passage que le secrét d'État à
l'enseignement supérieur à la recherche
et le premier ministère à avoir mis en
ligne des des données donc vous y avez
déjà accès dans un certain nombre de
secteur mais en ce qui concerne les
stages vraiment ils dépendent tellement
du bassin d'emploi local que leur
centralisation s'est avérée inefficace
même si l'idée est bonne donc pour ces
raisons je suis amené à donner un avis
défavorable bien monsieur le noir pour
explication de vote monsieur le
Président Madame la mini mes chers
collègues je trouve que l'intention
inscrite dans l'amendement était
extrêmement intéressante alors la
réponse de Madame le Ministre me laisse
quand même un peu perplexe parce que
vous avez l'air de considérer que les
pouvoirs publics c'est les pouvoirs
publics au niveau de l'état non les
pouvoirs publics ça peut-être également
au niveau régional au niveau
départemental au niveau local ce sont
les pouvoirs publics organisés qui
apportent un certain nombre de services
alors à partir de là l'amendement peut
très bien contte tenu de l'argumentation
que vous avez défendu être adopté et
concerné par un fléchage que vous avez
vous-même indiqué les pouvoirs publics
locaux
bien je mets au voix l'amendement 85 qui
est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement 85 n'est pas adopté le
86 même
vote NON je demande si c'est même vote
bien même vote donc il n'est pas adopté
après l'article 7 un amendement qui
n'est pas
défendu puis un autre le 91 madame
procaia
euh le le
86 non non il a été défendu le 91 euh
les il y a un problème dans les
disposition enfin dans le texte de loi
tel que il nous a été transmis de
l'Assemblée nationale les nouvelles
dispositions euh devait se s'appliquer
euh aux conventions on ne voudrait pas
qu'elle s'applique aux conventions de
stage euh qui ne sont signés et qui ont
été signés avant la publication des
décrets d'application
euh c'est aussi après l'article 7 euh
l'article
90 va un peu dans ce sens en disant que
la loi ne rentrera en vigueur que pour
la rentrée universitaire 2014-2015 alors
la loi devait s'appliquer au mois
d'avril et vous voulez que je présente
le
69 je présente le
69 le 69 et bien il se il se contente de
supprimer un mot de l'intitilé de la
proposition de loi puisque pour nous la
proposition de
loi tant à l'encadrement des stages et à
l'amélioration des stagiaires mais pas à
la au développement des stages puisque
ça va compliquer beaucoup les choses
bien je vous remercie chers collègues
monsieur le rapporteur si vous pouvez
aussi nous donner les votre avis sur les
trois amendements oui monsieur le
Président sur l'amendement 91 il est
logique que les dispositions de ce texte
qui nécessitent un décret d'application
ne seront pas applicable avant que
celui-ci soit publié c'est un principe
général et sur ce point cet amendement
est satisfait en revanche toutes les
dispositions de ce texte n'appelle pas
le décret la plupart sont d'application
directe et il faut pas retarder leur
mise en œuvre comme à chaque fois on
souhaite que les décrets soient pris le
plus rapidement possible sur le donc
c'est un avis défavorable sur
l'amendement 90 différit l'entrée en
vigueur en vigueur je tiens rassuré les
signataires de cet amendement le vote de
cette loi ne modifiera pas les
conventions de stage déjà signées elle
ne s'appliquera qu' conventions signé
postérieurement à son entrée en vigueur
et pour certaines dispositions à la
publication des décrets nécessaires donc
le but n'est pas de porter attete aux
conventions légalement conclu et par
contre il est contraire il est au
contraire nécessaire que que cette
proposition de loi achève son examen
parlementaire dans les meilleurs délis
pour qu'elle soit applicable dès que
possible quant à la dernière le dernier
le 69 j'ai mis un avis la Commission a
mis un avis désaccord complet quoi du
fait que le supprimer la motion la
motion développement alors queon voit
bien qu'il y a un développement tout à
fait important depuis quelques années
des stages donc c'est un avis de faavur
à pour les
trois madame la ministre également votre
avis sur les trois amendements s'il vous
plaît oui même avis pour les mêmes
raisons bien donc je vais mettre au voix
l'amendement
91 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient
l'amendement n'est pas
adopté t jour après l'article 7
l'amendement 90 qui est
pour qui est contre qui s'abstient il
n'est pas
adopté et enfin le 60 69 même vote même
vote il n'est pas adopté non
plus alors
donc on vote également sur
la alors je vais mettre au
voix l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
y a-t-il des demandes d'explication de
vote
oui oui madame proca déjà
oui euh benah d'abord je me félicite
qu'on termine le texte ce soir parce que
à avoir un ces séquences permanentes
c'est vraiment très désagréable et Ctait
comme je l'ai dit à un moment à se
demander si le gouvernement avait envie
que l'on vote ou pas ce texte parce que
vous l'avez présenté comme étant un
texte important et c'était parsemé tout
au long de l'emploi du temps quand il y
avait des trous bon pour notre part le
groupe UMP estime que c'est un texte
important de toute façon les la loi sur
les stages les lois sur les stages c'est
euh l'UMP et les gouvernements
précédents qui ont lancé toutes les
bases et le texte et vous l'aviez bien
dit d'ailleurs madame la ministre dans
votre intervention euh et effectivement
ce texte le complète et mais complexifie
en même temps euh des dispositions qui
existaient déjà et pour lesquelles on
aurait pu se contenter de prendre des
décrets qui n'étaient pas pris et
surtout on aurait pu si la volonté du
gouvernement était de faire un texte
c'est de faire un texte qui sanctionne
les entreprises euh qui ne sont pas qui
qui ne respectaient pas la
réglementation actuelle des stages là de
toutes les auditions que nous avons mené
nous avons compris que les choses
allaient faire encore un peu plus peur
aux entreprises en particulier au PME
qui sont pas armés pour ça et c'est une
des craintes du groupe UMP c'est que
effectivement l'offre de stage aille en
diminuant et non pas en
facilitant les les les offres euh je
l'ai dit tout à l'heure pour l'article 1
pour ma part j'estime qu'il y a un
certain nombre d'avancé
j'apprécie que la Commission et que un
certain nombre de collègues sur les
bancs divers a voté plus d'une une
dizaine d'amendements pour ma part je
m'abstiendrai donc sur ce texte en
espérant en espérant que dans la CMP un
certain nombre des avancées du Sénat
demeure euh mais le groupe UMP dans son
ensemble est opposé à
à la plupart de ses dispositions et donc
le groupe
EMP pour sa part sauf individuellement
certains d'entre nous votera contre ce
texte
bien madame Ferrat pour explication de
vote merci monsieur le président madame
la ministre mes chers collègu nous voici
donc arrivés à l'essue de ces débats
j'allais dire aussi enfin et je ne crois
trahir le sentiment de personne en
disant que l'examen de ce texte a semblé
interminable pourquoi pour la bonne et
simple raison qu'il s'est effectué dans
des condition proprement déplorable
comment a-t-on pu je ne trouve pas
d'autres mots ce soir saucissonné mais
c'est vraiment le mot qui convient à ce
point cette proposition qu'on en juge
une discussion à peine entamé le 29
avril poursuivi le 6 mai et c'est un
miracle si grâce à la bonne volonté de
chacun nous l'avons terminé aujourd'hui
et monsieur le Président tout à l'heure
nous a dit qu'il était encore prévu une
fenêtre mardi 27 mai nous y avons
échappé c'est un message très positif
envoyé aux jeunes vous en conviendrez
signe du grand cas que l'on fait de leur
sort et qui prouve à quel point on se
soucie de leur insertion dans l'emploi
quand au fond notre appréciation n'est
guerre plus positive et elle peut être
résumée en une formule celle de notre
collègue Jean-Léon Dupont le mieux est
l'ennemi du bien oui bien sûr il faut un
cadre minimal au stage et cela nous
l'avons toujours défendu le groupe et la
famille politique auquel j'appartient on
fait partie des plus actifs et des plus
mobilisés pour mettre en place un tel
cadre
je rappellerai que cela a été fait à
l'initiative de Jean-Louis borlot alors
ministre de l'emploi du travail et de la
cohésion sociale dans la loi du 31 mars
2006 pour l'égalité des chances
l'article 9 de cette loi légalisait la
convention de stage mettait en place une
gratification pour les stages longs et
limitait la durée maximale de ces stages
par la suite dans la loi ESR du 22
juillet 2013 madame la ministre que vous
connaissez parfaitement nous avons ont
fait adopter un amendement pour
interdire que les stages puissent servir
à pourvoir un emploi permanent dans
l'administration publique et les
associations et pas seulement dans les
entreprises ce cadre protège les
stagiaires et c'est bien normal mais le
présent texte va bien plus loin et bien
trop loin il crée un carcan rigide
totalement
antiéconomique en effet il établit des
contraintes nouvelles dont l'un des plus
embléma et sans doute celle du Cotat de
stagiaire par rapport aux effectifs de
l'entreprise et universalise celle qui
existait déjà conséquence ce cadre
nouveau est totalement inadapté à
certains secteurs d'activité et à
certains acteurs économiques exemple de
secteur d'activité celui d'
l'agriculture et de l'enseignement
agricole pour lequel vous l'avez compris
je me suis engagé comment voulez-vous
que la règle de la gratification et de
la durée maximale des stages y soit
applicable pour autant doit doit-on
arrêter de former les jeunes le résultat
risque donc d'être totalement
contre-productif puisqu'il conduira les
jeunes à ne plus trouver de stage pour
soi-disant mieux les protéger on va les
priver de cette voie d'insertion
privilégiée je dis privilégié et
j'ajoute aussi incontournable mais je
l'ai déjà tellement répété
puisque'aujourd'hui les stages sont
indispensables pour valider nombre de
formations le cadre mis en place par le
texte est aussi totalement incompatible
avec l'activité de certains acteurs
économiques tels que les PME et les
entreprises naissantes ces entreprises
ont besoin de stagiaire de manière plus
souple pour survivre prospérer et donc
créer de l'emploi parce que le stagiaire
d'aujourd'hui est le salarié de demain
c'est cela que l'on semble oublier
encore plus fondamentalement la
philosophie même de ce texte est très
problématique puisqu'il tend à faire
entrer le stagiaire dans un statut de
salariat c'est très grave parce que s
oublié que le stagiaire est avant tout
un jeune en formation parce que c'est
aussi aux antipodes du choc de
compétitivité et de simplification que
nous appelons de nos vœux et qui malgré
tous les pactes de responsabilité ne
semble toujours pas devoir se profiler
nous avions déposé un certain nombre
d'amendements visant à assouplir le
texte ils nonont malheureusement pas été
retenus dans ces condition madame la
ministre vous comprendrez que la très
grande majorité des membres du groupe
uduc vote contre le texte présent merci
de votre
attention madame Génisson pour
explication de
vote monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre monsieur le rapporteur mes
chers collègues la construction de
l'avenir des jeunes et j'en suis
persuadé une priorité politique que nous
partageons tous les jeunes viv vivent
aujourd'hui dans un environnement qui
n'est pas toujours facile à assumer une
longue phase de précarité le lot de
beaucoup d'entre eux et cela concerne
aussi beaucoup de ceux qui qui ont une
formation c'est dans ce contexte que les
stages ont connu néanmoins ces dernières
années un développement exponentiel pour
de bonne raison la professionnalisation
des études la capacité des entrants sur
le marché du travail à être rapidement
opérationnel et intégré dans le monde du
travail mais aussi pour de mauvaises
raisons l'utilisation de jeunes souvent
diplômés est immédiatement exploitable
dans un contexte de fort chômage et de
difficultés économiques le sujet du
développement des stages du statut des
stagiair occupe le législateur depuis de
nombreuses années ça a été dit par les
intervenants précédents je veux rendre
particulièrement hommage à notre
rapporteur qui depuis 2006 et au cours
de nos débats actuels a prouvé sa
compétence sa détermination son
engagement merci aussi à vous madame la
ministre pour qui avez été à l'écoute
des propositions émanant de nous tous et
nos débats ont été de grande qualité
même s'ils ont été longs avec ce nouveau
texte nous avons encore progressé nous
protégeons mieux les jeunes avec avec
des dispositions concernant la durée
concernant la durée des stages le
renforcement des missions des
établissements d'enseignement la
définition plus précise des tuteurs la
limitation du nombre de stagiaires par
enseignant et par entreprise la lutte
contre les abus de stagees avec
intervention de l'inspection du travail
nous avons adopté deux amendements très
importants à l'initiative de notre
rapporteur Jean-Pierre gaefroid l'un
pour l'augmentation de 90 € de la
gratification minimale l'autre pour que
cette gratification soit obligatoire
après mois de stage pour les stagiaires
de l'enseignement supérieur
contrairement à certains le groupe
socialiste ne pense pas que les
dispositions de ce texte vont arir
l'offre de stage nous soutenons que les
entreprises les collectivités les
associations dans leur grande majorité
souhaitent participer à la construction
de l'avenir des jeunes si la majorité
des organismes les accueille bien et
même avec plaisir il est important de
définir des règles pour éviter les
dérives les jeunes dès lors qu'ils sont
respectés seront d'autant plus motivés
ce texte est un signal fort pour
l'intégration de qualité dans le monde
du travail permettez-moi d'évoquer aussi
la qualité de nos travaux concertés sur
le sujet des stagiaires des Maisons
Familiales Rurales nous avons tous
évoqué ce sujet et merci au gouvernement
d'avoir trouvé d'avoir trouver le le bon
décret qui permet de d'intégrer de façon
satisfaisante ces stagiaires dans
effectivement un lieu d'enseignement qui
est tout à fait intéressant l'Assemblée
nationale a accompli une partie du
travail sur l'examen de cette
proposition de loi nous avons je le
pense encore amélioré le texte et le
groupe socialiste vtera ce texte issu de
nos débats très
constructifs bien monsieur revet pour
explication de vot oui merci monsieur le
Président Madame le Ministre madame
procacia a indiqué tout à l'heure quelle
était la position de notre groupe et je
le partage je fais partie de la très
grande majorité qui ne vont pas voter le
texte
parce que je suis inquiet je suis
inquiet des
conséquences de certaines dispositions
qui alourdissent les
procédures l'objectif l'obligation pour
des jeunes c'est de faire des stages or
pratiquement sur tous les
bancs nous avons dit que nous étions
souvent sollicités par des jeunes aux
abois qui ne trouvaient pas de stage et
leur diplôme étent en Cuse
je crains très franchement que les
dispositions qui
alourdissent les conditions pour les
entreprises pour l'accueil de ces jeunes
ne le fasse un recul d'un certain nombre
d'entre elles et que ce sera ce soit au
détriment des jeunes qui doivent être
notre objectif alors je souhaite que N
nous trompions mais je crains que ce
soit le cas et c'est pour ça que comme
la majorité du groupe je voterai contre
ce
texte madame Cohen pour explication de
vote oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre mes chers collègues je veux
tout d'abord remercier notre rapporteur
Jean-Pierre gaefroid parce que je trouve
qu'il était particulièrement attentif
tout au long des débats pendant la la
Commission et puis dans l'hémicycle et
qu'il a été fidèle à la proposition de
loi qu'il a fait en 2006 c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça qu'on s'est pas mal
retrouvé même si on n pas réussi à faire
adhérer l'ensemble de de l'hémicycle sur
un certain nombre de points donc je vais
commencer par les choses que nous
trouvons encore un peu trop frileuse ou
trop négative frileuse et trop négative
parce que y compris le candidat François
Hollande euh avait s'était avancé par
rapport à cet encadrement des stagiaires
et notamment avec avit promis une
allocation pour la jeunesse qui se fait
attendre et à mon avis qui ne va pas
voir le le jour malheureusement donc je
pense qu'on aurait pu faire preuve d'un
peu plus d'audace pour aider à encadrer
encore de meilleure façon les stagiaires
euh point négatif je regrette qu'une
partie de la gauche a voté avec la
droite un amendement qui a supprimé
l'alinéa 40 dans l'article 1er et qui
est très grave puisque je le lis le
temps de présence du stagiaire fixé par
la convention de stage ne peut excéder
la durée légale hebdomadaire de travail
fixé donc par l'article l31 21 100 du
Code du travail c'est-à-dire qu'on fait
exploser les 35 he ouvrant la porte à la
durée donc d'un temps de travail
incompatible avec de mon point de vue et
du point de vue de mon groupe un statut
d'élèv ou d'étudiants dignes du 21e
siècle donc j'espère que la CMP va
revenir là-dessus donc des points qui
sont qui sont effectivement négatifs
mais en même temps et heureusement la
loi et en tout cas dans dans son esprit
prend un certain nombre de positions qui
vont permettre de réduire
considérablement les les abus que
pouvait vivre les stagiaires et nous
nous nous nous réjouissons
particulièrement d'un encadrement par
rapport à ces à ces stagiaires notamment
dans l'université avec une limitation du
nombre d'étudiants ce qui est tout à
fait positif et donc un encadrement qui
va être bien meilleur d'un point de vue
d'un point de vue qualité nous nous
réjouissons également qu'un certain
nombre de nos amendements qui allaient
dans le sens de la philosophie donc de
de de cette loi et pu être adopté par
exemple en étendant à l'ensemble des
stagiaires même ceux ne bénéficiant pas
de gratification l'accès à la
restauration scolaire au titre
restaurant et à la prise en charge des
titres de transport de même en
permettant au stagiaires dans
l'impossibilité de poursuivre leur stage
d'avoir une autre possibilité de
validation offert par l'établissement
d'accueil ou le réconfort donc je crois
que tout ça c'est intéressant c'est
positif et je regrette que dans cet
hémicycle on a trop voulu faire peur en
tout cas dans une partie de l'hémicycle
en disant que en adoptant ces mesures
positives dans l'intérêt des stagiaires
et bien nous allions mettre en péril
l'avenir des entreprises je ne le crois
pas du tout je crois qu'au contraire ça
va permettre de modifier la qualité
aider à la qualité des stages et donc
apporter plus de sécurité pour les
futurs salair
sils sont ils sont embauchés c'est dans
ce sens donc que nous trouvons important
de voter cette proposition de loi et je
vous dis en espérant vraiment que lors
de la CMP et bien les les désagrements
qui ont pu être vootter peut-être par
fatigue lassitude ou par manque de
réflexion puisse être revu en tout cas
c'est ce que je pense bon je provoque
peut-être un peu à cette heure-là parce
que je crois que tout le monde a voté en
son âme et conscience mais ça vous
permet comme ça de montrer que vous êtes
toutes et tous attentif je vous
remercie bien monsieur des
cessard à mon avis est conservé oui euh
monsieur le Président Madame la Ministre
fallait
réglementer on est tous d'accord avec le
constat qu'il a des abus il a des abus
bien sûr ce sont les abus euh
de patron indélicat de chef d'entreprise
qui trouve une main d'œuvre au Bon
Marché motivé mais parfois aussi des
associations des entreprises en
difficulté qui bon prennent un stagiaire
pour parce queil y a pas les moyens de
faire autrement et également ça s'appuie
ces abus sur la détresse des jeunes qui
trouvent pas de premier emploi et qui
disent faut mieux que je fasse un stage
plutôt que rien faire et le stage me
permettra de rentrer dans l'entreprise
et cela 1 an 2 ans et 3 ans donc il
fallait réglementer et ce n'était pas
facile tant les situations étaient
différentes donc nous le groupe
écologiste on s'est situé dans la
logique présentée par la proposition de
loi soutenue par le gouvernement d'une
réforme cohérente d'un statut qui serait
le même pour chaque stagiaire en cela on
aurait pu et je comprends la logique
aussi défendue par l'UMP et l'UDI
de faire par secteur ça aurait été plus
long là certainement qu'on aurait
discuté plus longtemps
que
quece peut-être que ça aurait été
davantage adapté en tout cas là il y a
eu une stratégie par par rapport à cette
proposition de loi qui était de dire il
y a une cohérence globale et c'est le
même statut pour l'ensemble des
stagiaires cela sera le garde fou contre
les abus donc nous sommes situés dans la
stratégie de de la proposition de loi
qui a été respectée globalement et donc
nous voterons euh ce texte alors une
petite remarque générale c'est
que il fallait maintenir le mot
développement madame procacia dans le
titre de la proposition de voix je je
pense que les jeunes ont besoin de
s'investir dans entreprise le fait que
pour un certain nombre de de de jeunes
issus de milieu défavorisés le fait de
se sentir utile le fait de se coltiner à
la réalité de ne pas être en train
simplement d'écouter dans une classe de
25 ou 30 élèves le professeur pendant 6
ou 7 Hees dans la journée c'est quelque
chose de très important il faut
absolument développer la pratique et
encore une dernière
remarque
madame F vous avez dit quel est
l'intérêt pour une entreprise
d'accueillir je le sais que qu' il y a
un intérêt pour une entreprise et et
pour les tuteurs c'est de se sentir
utile c'est de transmettre un savoir
effectivement chacun est valorisé dans
l'échange dans le fait que les
connaissances restent pas inutiles mais
que on sent un jeune qui est prêt à
s'approprier
qui se se se motive et comment apprend
et c'est effectivement très enrichissant
à la fois pour le jeune et le formateur
donc je crois que nous défendons tous
l'idée
qu'il y ait plus de formation nous
considérons et c'est pour ça que nous
avons été contre certains amendements
qui tendaient à rapprocher le statut du
stagiaire du statut du statut de salarié
nous considérons qu'aujourd'hui le stage
fait partie de la formation il n'en sera
peut-être pas de même dans quelques
années si la situation économique ne
s'améliore pas et on pourra à ce
niveau-là être très inquier mais nous
parions sur le fait que il y a aura une
stabilité que j'espère que on pourra
s'en sortir économiquement autrement
c'est quand même tout le système social
qu'il faudra revoir en tout cas nous
avons nous sommes restés dans l'idée que
le stage est une période de formation
qu'il fallait réglementer contre les
abus le texte cette proposition de loi
correspond à cet objectif correspond à
cette stratégie et le groupe écologiste
votera donc cette proposition de
loi monsieur le noir pour explication de
vote oui monsieur le Président Madame la
ministre nous avons légiféré sur un
texte qui est parti d'un constat que
nous partagions à savoir qu'il y avait
des abus concernant les stages effectués
dans le cadre de l'enseignement
supérieur la preuve qu'on était sur
cette ligne là c'est que c'est Madame
fiorazo ministre en charge de
l'enseignement supérieur et de la
recherche qui représente le gouvernement
on aurait apprécié d'avoir plus
longtemps le ministre en charge des
affaires sociales et du travail on
aurait pu voir égal ement la présence du
ministre en charge de l'éducation
nationale donc ça voulait bien dire que
le texte visait comme nous l'avions
compris un certain nombre d'abut
constatés dans le cadre de
l'enseignement supérieur
soit à quoi avons-nous assister
finalement à un grand débat et au vote
d'un certain nombre de dispositions qui
reparlent d'une façon parfois un peu
pmelle des stages en entreprise de
l'apprentissage au point que parfois on
se demandait de quoi on
parlait alors si effectivement j'en ai
parlé et j'en parle encore maintenant
c'est bien pour montrer qu'il fallait
distinguer les
stages
des statuts
d'apprentis alors on en est arrivé à un
texte qui
malheureusement je ne veux pas juguger
le résultat risque d'aller à l'encontre
des jeunes dont nous avons beaucoup
parlé pendant ces débats qui cherchent
des stages pour valider une formation et
qui faut de stage ne peuvent pas obtenir
de poursuivre jusqu'à son terme leur
cursus
d'étude cette complexification fait
qu'effectivement on peut s'interroger
sur les effets par
du texte qui aura été délibéré et nous
parlons madame la Présidente non madame
Cohen non pas
tellement des entreprises mais nous
parlons bien de l'avenir des stagiaires
c'est bien de qu'il s'agit et c'est bien
eux que nous pensions quand nous avions
à plusieurs reprises les uns et les
autres sur différents bancs évoquer la
présence dans nos permanences de jeunes
qui désespérés nous demandaient le notre
aide pour avoir accès à un
stage alors mon premier mouvement de
même que celui de mes amis était de
voter contre pour autant il y a eu un
certain nombre d'avancées que je ne me
connais pas dû d'abord à l'écoute de
madame la ministre je le
reconnais vous avez écouté euh y compris
l'opposition lorsque nous avons évoqué
certains sujets et même nous avons eu
l'impression que dans les heures qui
avaient suivi notre séance de la semaine
dernière un certain nombre de démarches
avaient été accomplies qui vous
permettaient de vous rapprocher de
d'organisme de formation dont nous vous
parlions c'est dû également à l'attitude
de Monsieur rapporteur certains pourront
évidemment évoquer la solidarité
territoriale qui nous uni en
bassnormandie elle n'est pas suffisante
pour dire que j'ai apprécié la façon
dont notre rapporteur a conduit la
mission qui lui a été confié il y a eu
surtout un certain nombre d'avancées
dont une à laquelle je tenais
particulièrement et qui concernait et
les maisons familiares rurales moi je
prends acte qu'il y a eu des avancé nous
y avons les uns et les autres
contribués les maisons familiales rural
nous ont fait savoir qu'elles avaient
beaucoup apprécié la façon dont les
choses s'étaient déroulé et la façon
dont nous avions finalement conclu le
débat c'est la raison pour laquelle sans
avoir l'idée que je me désolidarise de
qui que ce soit je m'abtiendrai sur le
vote de ce texte
bien je vais donc mettre au voix
et
comment oui et bien je je viens de voir
mais je ne vous avez pas donc
excusez-moi mais vous pouvez donc
intervenir je vous en prie madame
Laborde excusez-moi monsieur le
Président de ma spontanéité mais il me
semblait que justement je voilà merci
donc monsieur le Président Madame la
Ministre vu les efforts du gouvernement
pour accepter un certain nombre
d'amendements par exemple en effet
concernant les Maisons familiales
rurales ou sur certains avantages tels
lesétickets restaurant ou titre de
transport pour tous les stagiaires et
enfin le dernier visant à inciter
l'embauche des jeunes de moins de 26 ans
qui passeraient du statut de stagiaire à
celui de salarié en CDI tous les membres
du RDSE voteront cette proposition de
loi madame la ministre monsieur le
rapporteur merci merci d'avoir permis
l'évolution du statut des stagiaires qui
parfois était utilisé selon la vilain
expression entendue ce soir je me
permettrai d'insister sur l'amendement
115 qui a été très discuté et ce serait
dommage qu'il disparaisse en commission
mixte paritaire ma chère collègue je
nous pensons le contraire de ce que vous
avez dit tout à l'heure et je peux vous
confirmer que l'amendement de Monsieur
Barbier n'est pas le fruit de la fatigue
mais bien celui de la réflexion je vous
remercie
bien
donc cette fois je vais donc
procéder au vote j'ai été d'ailleurs
saisi d'une demande de scrutin public
par les groupes UMP et socialiste sur
l'ensemble de la proposition de loi il
doit donc être procédé au scrutin public
dans les conditions fixé par l'article
56 du règlement euh le scrutin sera
ouvert donc quelques
minutes quelques instants
même bien le scrutin est
ouvert résultat du scrutin numéro 183
sur l'ensemble de la proposition de loi
euh nombre de votants 344 nombre de
suffrages exprimés
331 pour l'adoption 181 contre
150 le Sénat a adopté la proposition de
loi tendant au développement à
l'encadrement des stages et à
l'amélioration du statut des
stagiaires voilà pour l'adoption de
cette proposition de loi relative au
développement et à l'encadrement des
stage je vous rappelle que chaque année
en France ce sont pas moins de 1,2
million d'étudiants qui découvrent le
monde de l'entreprise grâce au stagees
les sénateurs vous l'avez vu ont
largement uvré pour améliorer leurs
conditions de vie avec notamment une
augmentation de la gratification
mensuelle des stagiaère qui passe ainsi
de 436 à 523 € par mois qui sera
obligatoire à partir de 2 mois de stage
je vous rappelle le cheminement de ce
texte ce texte avait d'abord été adopté
une première fois par la Assemblée
nationale au mois de février puis il a
été modifié par le Sénat au mois de mai
enfin sénateurs et députés sont arrivé à
un compromis à la fin du mois de juin et
ce texte qui a été publié le 11 juillet
2014 entrera en vigueur à partir de
septembre 2015 vous pouvez toujours voir
et revoir toutes les séances sur notre
site sur public sénatfr très bonne fin
de journée sur les chaînes
parlementaires